hello everyone welcome to bdc planning
committee for the 25th of august
i will ask the government's office to
read out the domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations for you thank you
thank you chair
please ensure that whilst sorry please
ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or if you are exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations while us others
are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app so please
good members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
fire safety arrangements if you hear the
alarm leave the building immediately via
a fire exit and make your way to the
assembly point on ipswich town football
ground follow the signs directing you to
the exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium if you are in
the atrium at the time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit
use the stairs not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until it is safe
to do so
i'd like to remind everyone present at
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or excited items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to consider consented to being
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
will broadcast this meeting when the
public and press are not lawfully
excluded
thank you chair thank you claire
make some introductions we have our
legal advisor
into pray
we have uh strategic projects and
delivery manager stephen stone i'm sure
that title gets longer every week
we have our government officer claire
philpott we have case officers jasmine
weinman wyard
linda bacon and
owen behind me
and also present we have simon bailey
heritage and planning compliance and
peter chisner environmental management
officer
thank
you
claire apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor suez and councillor adrian
osborne and councillor michael holt is
substituting for councillors
thank you
do we have any decorations for cuny and
non-pecuniary interest by members
councillor parker
thank you chad um in respect to dc 21
007
the urgent item of viewers i've
previously declared a pecuniary interest
in this item by virtue of the fact that
i've got a business relationship with
the applicant's agent so
i will declare the same again and i'll
leave the chamber at that that item sure
thank you
parker
noted
item three
um the minutes are not quite yet
available so they would defer them to
the next meeting
notification of petitions
non-received chair thank you
and requests for site inspections
number saved thank you
sorry
sorry mr chairman you went a bit quick
um the minute
what what what is the delay
i don't know
but i will ask you a question thank you
uh
thank you chair uh the minutes are in
draft form we're just waiting on them
being confirmed before we can send them
round so they will be available for the
next meeting
who has to confirm them
they need to be confirmed by our
planning officers
the area planning manager
and the chief planning officer
thank you
no request for site visits sorry coach
barron
right sorry
just for clarification is the the minute
wording anything to do with the um draft
for the resolution on the hadley um
industrial unit sites
because that was sort of subject to
officers coming up with a resolution on
that yeah that that's a slightly
different point council about so the
minutes will record
the minutes and officers will be
returning to you at a later date um to
go through the rivers associated with
the resolution thank you
thank you
any more questions on the non-existent
minutes
okay moving on
schedule for planning applications
dc 21
sorry sorry mr chairman um just under
site inspections
do we know
when the great corner plan of
application has come to committee it's a
baby district council-owned
uh property
land and they want to build four
bungalows there is is this
well it will be coming to committee
um do we know when
because i'm considering whether i'd like
to ask for a site inspection i'm not
sure yet but i i need a bit more time
for a chair
unless um stephen can
come in i don't believe we we've got a
date for that
yet so i can let you know when we do
thank you
moving on
dc stroke 2101
073 land to the north east and east of
bobbitt's lane winsted suffolk
i will now ask the case officer jasmine
wyatt to introduce the application to
the committee
thank you
thank you chair and good morning members
i'm presenting an application at the
site land to the north and east of
bobbit's lane in worsted today
the application is reserved matters for
the scale appearance landscaping and
layout for commercial development
members are reminded that this
presentation should be viewed in
conjunction with the committee report
and should not be viewed in isolation
the outline application was approved by
members in july 2020 and the development
description of the outline development
is on the screen now
notably adjacent to the site a full
planning application for a petrol
filling station and takeaway restaurant
was also approved by members in july
2020 which is associated with this
employment application and contains the
same highways works to the roundabouts
as this application
whilst flexible employment use for b1c
b2 and b8 uses was granted this was
primarily as the application was
speculative at the time
and thus flexibility enabled the
developer
to market the site to a range of
potential end users and be responsive to
market demands
as you will see from the site layout and
elevations um which will be presented
later in this presentation all the units
are now to be brought forward as b8 uses
so here we have um the outline plans
that are relevant to this submission so
the outline submission included an
indicative site layout plan which is on
the left hand side of the screen there
condition four of the outline ties the
reserve matters to be in general
conformity with this plan which i will
discuss later in the presentation
the other key aspect of the outline were
upgrades to the current teardrop
roundabouts at junction 56
as part of this further cycling
pedestrian
and pedestrian infrastructure
improvements were also included such as
crossing and crossings and paths
these works being agreed and constructed
under a section 278 agreement with
suffolk county council highways
which is currently being progressed um
with both them and highways england
a traffic regulation order is also being
progressed to create a 40 mile per hour
speed limit along the a137
around the site
so the site is shown by the red pin in
the center of the screen here and lies
within western um with ipswich to the
north
to the east is the a137
and then you have the aom the a14
running south of the site with the
junction 56 connecting the site in um
onto the a137
the port felix does also located to the
east which has now got free port status
site extends 8.04 hectares with the
further additional landscape landscaping
area proposed to the north as shown in
the next slide and you can also see
there where the petrol filling station
and drive-through restaurant were
approved
so again we have a site location plan so
the blue area to the north is to be
retained as associated landscaping
the the plan also shows how the petrol
filling station relates to the proposal
and also includes the previously
approved roundabout upgrades as well
the site falls in level towards the
north with the most visible area being
the southern part of the field
which was again previously approved for
the petrol filling station
so in terms of constraints um the site
itself has is not constrained by any
sort of designation um as you can see
there however there are nearby public
rights away which include footpaths and
rideaways which are shown by the green
dashed lines
the nearest list of buildings are along
the street and to the south there
and the suffolk coast and heath's area
of outstanding natural beauty is located
east shown by the green shaded area
so here is an aerial view primarily
showing the southern area of the site
and as you can see it does slightly fall
in level towards the north
this is the northern area of the site
and taken from the a137 this the photo
gives you an idea of the site's visual
contribution to the area
it's notable that there are electricity
pylons running across this area of the
site
which just for members information is
not to be developed is to be retained as
landscaping areas associated with this
application
a landscape and visual impact assessment
was submitted with the application which
concluded this particular area of the
site to the north um already has a
slightly more urbanized appearance as a
consequence of the the electricity
pylons than the remainder of the site as
existing which is comprised of
agricultural land
so here we have the site layout and
showing a mixture of commercial space
and landscaping on site it's important
to note that the southern area would all
be developed and both by this
application and the associated and the
associated petrol filling station
um therefore retaining the northern area
for landscaping would provide a softer
landscape transition space before
reaching ipswich to the north
a snippet of the outline plan is shown
on the left um as i mentioned earlier
condition four of the outlines sought to
ensure any reserve matters were broadly
in accordance with this plan
and this was primarily to avoid one
large industrial building being
developed which was one potential option
shown at the outline stage
as you can see what has been developed
is broadly in accordance with that plan
and notably five buildings were proposed
which has now been reduced down to four
the removal of unit d on the outline
plan
has enabled more landscaping and a
softer approach to be adopted on the
corner of the site which is the key
focal area as you approach off of
junction
56. significant landscaping has been
proposed to the northern area of the
site
amongst this landscaping there would be
an attenuation basin retained woodland
and hedgerows along the southern
boundary adjacent to all the commercial
units
earth mounding meadow long grass and
wetland mixes to support ecology
as i mentioned earlier four buildings
are proposed
all are two stories save for unit a
which is three stories and is located in
the north west corner of the site
all buildings faiths face southwards
except for unit d which faces faces
eastwards into the spine road and
landscaping is incorporated into the
site including trees and amenity grass
with a thick buffer along the eastern
side there
a range of surfacing materials are used
across site which is to highways
approval which helps aid legibility
around the site
cycle shelters and seating areas are
also scattered across the units
adequate parking is incorporated into
the site which is in surplus to what
would be required for a b8 use class
i've only shown elevations of unit a
just as this is the largest unit
however members should note that all
units adopt a very similar appearance
and utilize the same materials key
design
aspects such as sort of glazed areas and
the
colours as well
the colours used were considered
appropriate by landscaping and aomb
offices
following negotiation of sort of earlier
lighter and colors that were going to be
used
finally um this this slide shows you the
street scenes of
units a and b within the northern area
of the site
just to give you a feeling on how how
that would look
as you can see the elevational
treatments would vary slightly but the
site as a whole would they would be
coherent
as i mentioned earlier in terms of the
overall design the colours and the the
key design aspects
the site is in a key location along the
a14 easily accessible to ipswich and
felix stowe
and the approved approval of the reserve
matters is the first stage in delivering
new jobs and supporting the economy
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the application subject to
conditions thank you for listening
thank you jasmine
see my crib shooting now
do we have any questions from the
members to the officer
councillor would you like to start
thank you mr chairman um
three
quick questions i i suspect uh you
mentioned felix dough and free sport
status i didn't think the free ports
have been uh have been announced yet i
know they've applied for free port
status but i don't know whether they got
it yet
second point is what's the gross floor
area of the units
uh
outline versus reserve matters
and which one's three story again
uh thank you councillor hinton um so in
terms of the freeport apologies if that
is probably my mistake um
it obviously as you say has it has been
applied for um so that's really just to
give you an idea of sort of the the
reason that it's ba more than anything
um in terms of the the gross floor area
and so in terms of condition four as i
sort of have mentioned several times
i'll just uh get up here
so condition four um basically on on the
basis of what was submitted at the
outline and the indicative outline plan
we had said that it should provide a
maximum of 17 020 square meters of floor
space
however um this has increased to 20 312
square meters
but um i would sort of note that this
this is enabled by the condition which
does say unless otherwise agreed in
writing by the local planning authority
which obviously this is a mechanism to
do that
um and also it has been done primarily
by creating internalized
floor space as i mentioned there is um
one building which is unit a so it is
the largest building um that is to be
three stories
um as i say the overall footprint you've
lost a building which is sort of how
that that build up um
has primarily been accommodated
um so although the floor space has
increased the footprint and overall
landscaping which is primarily the
steering reason that that condition was
put on
um that has that has been accommodated
on site so we've effectively achieved
what what we set out to do by that
condition
mclaren
thank you chair
uh
i ask about i i use this junction two or
three times a week
and um i'm just concerned about the
access so the petrol station will have a
separate access to the site that we're
considering today or is it just one big
access road
off of the 137.
um so first of all the the access
matters we're all dealt with at the
outline stage so probably need to um
sort of avoid going over those now
having said that um i don't know if we
could maybe get the slides up on the
screen it might be easier to show you
um
so i don't know if you can see there um
effectively the the roundabouts are
being upgraded under as i mentioned the
section 278 um agreement works with
suffolk county council and highways
england
um there is one access into the site um
off of that roundabout however there is
obviously a different access into the
the drive-through and petrol filling
station
thank you thank you
thank you
um is it the intention that the
works to the roundabouts will be
completed before
any work on this development starts
yes so there are 36 conditions that were
imposed on the outline permission and so
it was quite front loaded
um but effectively no no works and no
use of either of those sites can start
until the roundabouts have been done and
the spine roads and everything is in and
taking account obviously the the traffic
impact that would arise from um the two
developments together as well
and if you could go to slide 13
you talked about uh
the
trees on the
edge on the a137 there are there are one
or two gaps already in existence there
and it does show that the gaps
remain on that slide but you said
there's going to be quite a heavy
boundary
of trees um
are they planning to infill the gaps
um so yeah basically the the idea is um
that obviously as you say there are some
gaps along there at the minute um there
are
going to be um some increases in the
trees along that that edge along with
you know hedgerows and and whatnot um
this has been assessed by play services
landscaping
and they're content that this creates a
good enough buffer um to reduce the
visual impact and obviously create that
sort of soft transition that you you
currently get um going along the a137 in
terms of the obviously this is not not
indicative but it does show you know the
approximate locations of trees
um so i would imagine that this will
sort of obviously as they mature and um
[Music]
i suppose fill out
um it is expected that this won't be you
know it's not a scattering of trees it
will be quite thick um but you might
want to ask and clarify that with the
applicant as well
thank you chair
um you're saying the report that the
number of cycle spaces and um ev
charging points going to be
secured by
recommendation
condition sorry um i've wondered who's
going to set the number is that so we're
going to set or is that going to be left
to the applicant and um
how many spaces we would we
be looking to secure
so it will be done primarily in
accordance and conversation with suffolk
county council highways and obviously
their their parking guidance does set um
cycle standards and sort of how many how
many cyclists we're going to need
and spaces for
obviously there will be an element of
the applicant will have to discharge any
condition that we put on so
they're they're within their rights to
apply for however many spaces they they
require on site and obviously that would
be subject to us assessing it alongside
suffolk county council highways
um i'm not sure entirely on the number
of spaces we'd propose at the minute but
obviously it would be um dealt with
under that sort of conversation with
suffolk county council to their
satisfaction
any more questions members
nope
okay we'll move on
public speakers we do not have a speaker
in the parish council
or an objector or a supporter but we do
have the applicant mr andrew philemon
phil moore that correct
you have three minutes to address
the committee
thank you chair members for the
opportunity to speak this morning
pigeon as a suffolk-based company are
committed to bringing forward high
quality deliverable and sustainable
schemes across the county whilst
respecting existing communities and
providing significant infrastructure
benefits
industrial and logistics is at the apex
of the fundamental changes in how we
live and consume and the rapid growth in
this sector is driving high demand for
new space
the rise of e-commerce and technological
advances have thrust the sector forward
from a largely supportive function to a
pivotal strategic role in meeting
consumer needs
the shift to e-commerce has stimulated
demand as logistics operators retailers
and parcel carriers try to meet the
changing needs of
consumers
with the national trend generating
significant demand for new high quality
logistic space along key transport
corridors such as a14 this reserve
matters application looks to meet this
demand through the provision of four
high quality bespoke buildings which are
designed to meet occupy demand and is
supported by a comprehensive landscaping
and ecological scheme which will deliver
a net gain in biodiversity
the early delivery of this site will
support inward investment and
infrastructure improvements including
the transformational upgrade of junction
56 which is to be fully funded by
private investment
additionally in going beyond policy
requirements and at the request of the
parish council the application includes
a package of measures which will help
tackle anti-social motorcycle activity
in the vicinity in summary this reserve
matters application will provide the
following key benefits
much-needed high-quality bespoke
logistic space on a key transport
corridor which will create circa 300
full-time jobs alongside temporary
construction jobs
an upfront infrastructure investment of
6 million pounds to deliver highway
improvements and the necessary services
with a total construction spend estimate
of 20 million pounds site layout which
is in conformance with the requirements
of the outline permission
provision of 4.3 hectares or 10.6 acres
of land for new planting which will
enhance biodiversity and provide
suitable new landscaping and inclusion
of a package of measures as recommended
by the parish council to assist in
tackling anti-social motorcycle activity
thank you i'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
thank you do you have any questions
counselor baron do you want to get a
call uh yeah thanks um is this purely
speculative or have you got uh tenants
lined up
because you did say about bespoke nature
of the buildings so that sounds as if
you have got tenants potentially
that is correct um so when we um
achieved outline planning consent i
think september last year we commenced a
marketing exercise we knew before then
there was quite strong demand and we
have secured agreement with tenants so
for example building a a company lay and
wheeler are going in there they are a
wine
not storage and distribution they store
fine wine for long periods of time
correct um so they're going in in unit a
the
other units commercial discussions are
close to being finalized obviously one
of the um the requirements from the end
users of that is to have a reserve
matters consent and a deliverable scheme
so just in terms of the timings of that
the section 278 works with the county
harvest authority in harris england
clearly is nearly um finalizing expect
that to be finalized quarter three
of this year with construction um
starting on the highways works in
quarter four there will probably be a
break um or there will be a break over
the christmas period obviously high
volumes and generally poor weather
construction of the roundabouts and the
rest of the highway work will finish
quarter one january february and 22 with
building a completed the lane wheeler
towards um the middle end of 22
and then the rest of the units built out
by 2023
thank you mr chairman um
you heard the concern um raised about
the electric charging points um could
you just assure us that you will
attempt to get as many as possible
provided there because not just for the
motors but also to your larger vehicles
that perhaps are coming into the
industrial units it is important that we
do
do as many as possible
and as this is completely new so
the opportunities are there uh no yes i
completely agree with that
um uh obviously the current policy
requirements is for 20
um of the parking spaces to have ev
charging
and a further 20 percent to have be
ducked ready i.e ready to install the
chargers obviously that's set out in the
county council's parking standards
as a minimum we will comply with that
we are finalizing discussions with our
end users to go above that
and i think it's it's clear in the
discussions to date there is a
thrust from
all occupiers
mindful of
of of of the climate crisis and also
their kind of commercial images to
deliver sustainable development and it's
highly likely will go quite quite far
beyond that requirement in terms of even
charging
for the applicant answer jason
sir
it's a couple of questions um you
mentioned that you're
you will fit pv sales if if required i
mean is that going to
be something you're definitely going to
do or just if pushed uh no um we
definitely will um all the buildings
will have have fpv on them and in terms
of the extent of pv it it depends
um because obviously one of the
requirements or the benefits of
providing roof lights on a building is
you get natural light coming into and
obviously reducing the need to use
electricity for lighting etc etc
um so it depends on the extent of
roof lights that we provide so building
a lane wheeler
obviously it's storing wine and
therefore there won't be roof lights on
that particular building and we would
have more pv
than otherwise but as uh um definitely
every single building would have pv on
it
and that's the other quick i see from
your report you're looking to get a
green rating of very good that's great
yes just wondered why stop it very good
why not push for excellent or even
outstanding um
yes so the um obviously one of the
conditions on the outline consent
requires those details to be provided we
have discharged that condition
and that the requirement on us is that
as a minimum we will meet very good
again it's a similar sort of
conversation with the end users
like the amount of electric vehicle
charging how far we go beyond that um
correct we are we are looking at going
beyond that but as a minimum we will
meet very good standards pretty much
standards thanks
any more
no thank you very much
we do have a ward member present so um
we'll move into
a debate
anybody would like to kick us off
wrong counselor barrett you're first in
the open um well i actually uh
support this application it makes sense
and i bang on about the lack of
provision of
employment land in babur so this was
full strain to my lap
so i'm very happy to propose this if i
can have a second
there's not a lot to discuss i don't
think they're very full presentation
uh also uh no one else is represented so
there's no other areas i can see that
we've really got to discuss
um improvements in the highway and i
believe that six million pounds of
improvement
so that's like free grasses isn't it so
um another one that suffolk county
council can get away with so it's all
very good stuff
so uh i'd like to close them if i have a
second to please
i severe um thank you
chairman yes i'll second that i remember
when it came to us for the outline we
did debate this fully and for some time
so uh i think most of the facts or all
of the facts should have been sorted and
very pleased to hear from the applicant
that he's going to try and go further
and beyond what is expected so that's
all good news
that's case be it
country hitting you have a comment to me
yes mr chairman um
yes i agree with
councillor barrett in terms of provision
of employment land etcetera
as long as it's increased capacity but
i've a feeling here that we're talking
about a lot of
business activity from elsewhere across
the district being moved to this one
location a bit like we did with the the
giant
food pro
place at uh
sprout and on the sugar beak factory
site which basically just collected all
the individual sites that the the
operator had scattered around suffolk uh
and brought them to one location
so i think we've got to be a little bit
careful about uh all these things yes
it's nice to know that they're going to
stay in the area
probably would have been even nicer if
somebody had talked about the
possibility of providing access to the
to the railway line so that
freightline could come in and out by
train because it's after all it runs
down the back of that site right can get
much closer
and also the other thing that concerns
me a little bit is the impact on
the 137 down into ipswich
it's already quite a busy route that
roundabout is chopped up solid in the
evenings and quite often in the mornings
and if there is a problem on the orwell
bridge and i know it it has improved
slightly from the point of view that
they're now putting variable speed
limits on there when the weather is
inclement
but the other day there was a five hour
closure of the orwell bridge when
somebody threatened to jump off it
and then all the traffic of course gets
routed down the 137 and into ipswich so
it is a major diversion route and that
should be born in mind as well when it
comes to traffic implications which i
don't think suffolk county council
highways do actually take any notice of
thank you councillor hinton
any more comments
councillor busby
thank you yes i'm just uh pleased to see
that the developers have worked with
closely with the parish council to
resolve the issues of the the
motorcycles that have been uh a bane in
the lives of the residents of that
particular area for
many a year and hopefully you will
successfully
sort the problem out
which i think you promised to do quite a
few years ago actually but uh
we'll get there in the end thank you
any more comments
if not we have a proposal can i ask the
officer
to conduct the vote don't forget this
electronically
thank you chair
members if you go to your mod
app and select the plus time in the top
right hand corner
the vote for this item is now in
progress
thank you chair that's 10 votes for it
that's 10 votes for for approval thank
you
thank you everyone
sorry can i have a quick five-minute
break there's nothing new sorry
your five-minute break
thank you all
we're now back in business
we have planning application dc 21
00357 land north east of churchfield
road chilton industrial state children's
suburban suffolk
and linda bacon is the officer for
representatives
thank you linda
thank you chair and good morning members
so this is a full planning application
and it's for the erection of plant and
machinery for development and operation
of a standby energy generation facility
on land on the chilton industrial estate
before i start the presentation proper
there is an addendum paper that was
circulated prior to the meeting which
corrects a couple of pointless points of
error
as summarized here so the first point
is to
clarify comments from our internal
consultee response
it just clarifies or tidies the wording
the second point is to add
reference to our saved policy cno6 into
the list of
policies the third correction is at
paragraph 4.14 that's updated to confirm
that
policy cs15 is
afforded full weight
and finally the recommendation
is updated to add noise level condition
and any others as recommended by
environmental protection officers and to
the list of suggested conditions
so moving on this aerial map shows the
location of the site on the northern
side of chilton industrial estate which
is an allocated employment area
the royal mail delivery office is to the
south east and there are offices to the
north west
with mary's church that's to the north
that's a submitted site location
plan which i'll
move on from
this
map shows the constraints affecting the
site now mary's church to the north is
grade 1 listed
there is a footpath adjacent to the rear
boundary
of the site and the the site is beyond
the
built-up area boundary for sudbury and
that's shown by the brown line to the
south west
can we zoom in on that
so this is the proposed site layout
it comprises three containerized
generators towards the rear
here
there's a battery and transformer unit
here
and there's a switch gear and control
room here
and then the building towards the front
here is for the distribution network
operator
there's also a gasket just to the
side
the facility is enclosed by 4.4 metre
high timber fencing
on three and a half sides
um
oh i can't control the mouse very well
at this point
here it becomes 5.5 meter high acoustic
fencing adjacent to the generators
the area at the front is enclosed by one
meter post and rail fencing and the area
to the side
is enclosed by 2.4 meter paladin fencing
can we back up out of that
thank you
so moving on to the elevations the top
image is to the side elevation facing
south east towards the route the royal
mail delivery office
the bottom image is to the front
elevation
on the top image the
fencing here is 4.4 metre high timber
fencing
beyond that are the three generators and
behind that
is the 5.5 metre high acoustic fencing
and the office building is situated
behind
so the bottom image
has four meter high timber fencing
across the frontage
um with post and rail fencing in front
of that
and then to the left side
is
paladin fencing
which is 2.4 meters high and it clearly
shows the office building
to the side
so here the top image is the side
elevation facing northwest towards the
office building
you've got the acoustic fencing
at five and a half metres high it then
dips down to four meter high timber
fencing and the intervening area is
enclosed by the 2.4 metre high paladin
fencing the bottom image is the rear
elevation with the offices to the right
side
these are elevations with the existing
planting shown
top image is towards the royal mail
delivery office bottom image is to the
front
the side elevation towards the office
is shown in the top image and then the
bottom image is the rear elevation
towards the footpath
to the rear
so this landscaping plan shows that the
existing planting
to the left hand side
will be supplemented
with additional planting um and there'll
be additional planting along the the
site frontage
so the enclosed land to the northwest
will include low mounds
to provide translocation areas for
reptiles
with wildlife a herbenaculum adjacent
so
that's described the development of the
site but
what is its actual purpose so it's
a standby generation facility that will
become operational during times of peak
demand
for electricity in the area when it
would be called upon by national grid to
combust natural gas from the mains grid
to generate electricity which is then
exported to the sudbury primary located
nearby off waldenfield road the
application is for a temporary period
around 20 to 25 years and is fully
reversible
so peak demand periods are anticipated
to be uh between 7 30 and 9 in the
morning and between 4 and 8 30 in the
evening with higher operating hours
during the winter months
so if the wind isn't blowing or the sun
isn't shining then along
sorry i should say if the wind is
blowing and the sun is shining then
along with other sources of generated
electricity there may be enough power
however if there's a lack of wind or sun
or an existing generating facilities out
of commission then the national grid
calls on emergency generators through
its short-term operating reserve as is
the case here to make sure there's
enough electricity to meet demand and
that the network is balanced
the maximum operating hours applied for
here are two and a half thousand hours
per year and the anticipated operational
hours of the facility are likely to mean
that the facility will be needed around
50
of the maximum
so this is so this gas generator may run
for approximately two and a half
thousand year hours per year mostly
during the winter to provide sufficient
electricity either directly or through
battery storage
to supply over 22 000 homes during those
peak times
the facility is essentially an interim
measure or a stepping stone to maintain
an electricity supply at peak demand
until the network is fully decarbonized
in the future
hence the proposal is considered to
support the transition to renewable
energy production
returning to the slides
uh
this is an aerial photo kindly submitted
by the occupier of the adjacent offices
and it gives a good view of the site
which is
here
and in relation to the offices adjacent
on the left side and the church beyond
so this view is north west with offices
just visible
the bottom view is south east towards
the royal mail building
this is the adjacent offices
the application site is the right hand
side in the bottom image
this is the
view of the royal mail overflow car part
which is to the south east of the site
and the
piling contractors base is the bottom
right image and that's on the opposite
side of the road
this is the view over the site from the
royal mail overflow car park and the
bottom image shows the lavender leisure
building on the right hand side and
that's opposite
the adjacent offices
so
mary's church is to the north of the
site
and it has a footpath heading south east
from the church which is just shown on
the right hand side of the bottom image
so this
is a view from the footpath that runs
along the rear of the application site
looking back towards the church
and the bottom image is the viewer of
the opposite view so that's the footpath
heading south east
along the site boundary which is on the
right hand side of the hedge
[Applause]
so to to sum up
gas peaking facilities have a critical
role to play in the medium term in the
uk energy market the facility is carbon
generating however it is an interim
arrangement maintaining electricity
supply at peak demand only until the
energy network is fully decarbonized
the need for the facility will diminish
over time and ultimately it will
disappear
the life span is 20 to 25 years and is
conditioned accordingly along with a
five-year monitoring regime in respect
to the continued need for the facility
so on the face of it and in isolation of
wider national guidance the proposal
which relies on the burning of gas which
is a fossil fuel
is contrary to those elements of policy
cs 13 and 15 that seek to minimise
dependence
on fossil fuels and to address climate
change
however there are also elements within
both these policies that pull in
different directions for this specific
proposal
in addition to minimizing dependence on
fossil fuels policy cs13 also offers
support for proposals that include
on-site low or zero carbon technologies
and policy
cs15 goes on to support the use of
sources of low-carbon energy to mitigate
climate change
this is an application for a gas peaking
facility which can be considered to be
low carbon
as expressed by the 2020 government
energy white paper
and that's because of its role in
transitioning to renewable sources
the dependency on fossil fuels for this
proposal as mentioned in policy cs13 is
over a time limited period and will
reduce to zero within its 25 year
um
lifespan
the site is appropriately appropriately
located on an industrial state and the
scheme is not subject to any outright
objection from the extensive number of
local technical consultees which include
the local highway authority your
environmental management and protection
officers the heritage officer and the
council's ecology consultant
there is also an absence of objection
from national consultees including the
environment agency historic england and
natural england however there are
objections and concerns from chilton
parish council suffolk preservation
society and a large number of local
residents and other businesses
whilst the proposal doesn't comply with
all aspects of the development plan the
proposals sufficiently caused with the
majority of the plan the lack of any
other technical issues is weighed in the
planning balance against identified
conflict with elements of policies cs13
and cs15
and subject to the
suggested conditions
the scheme can be said to accord with
the plan as a whole and is acceptable
planning permission is therefore
recommended as per the conditions in
your papers
thank you
thank you linda
are there any questions for the officer
councillor parker
thank you chair um
linda two and a half thousand hours
maximum per year that's still
roughly seven hours a day
one imagines if if this plant had to run
for seven hours a day it's answered the
need for why it needs to be there but
nonetheless how do we monitor that two
and a half thousand hours how are those
hours recorded of usage
we're recommending imposing a condition
and
we can build into that the there will be
a log kept by the applicants
that's the number of hours used
that could be checked
thanks jameson
are you
are you considering um that gas which
fossil fuel is a low carbon technology
it seems to be what you're saying in
your report
um it can be considered as low carbon
technology because of the wider picture
in the role it plays in being able to
facilitate transition
to a fully decarbonized
network in the future and government
paper the white paper recognizes that
as a low-carbon position
and another thing you seem to be giving
a lot of weight to the applicant's
briefing day which draws on the
government white paper
and um
having looked at the white paper i can't
see that it doesn't seem to be
concluding that gas has a future i
wonder why you're giving so much weight
to a white paper
the white paper is a material
consideration
the
main
assessment rests on the the
policies of the load of the plan and
read as a whole
so
the white paper is mentioned um because
of its
how it fits into the wider scheme and
the direction that the government views
um the use of these gas peaking plants
as a transitionary
um means to to get to a renewable end
when i look at the white paper it
wouldn't even it doesn't seem to mention
the gas
he's it's got a future but um i was
wondering where he was getting that but
and one other thing can i ask the
sustainability officer a question here
or just the
can i ask the sustainability officer a
question or just at this stage or not
peter choose them
if you're happy with that
okay
um
just um initially you objected to this
application and then based on the
incorrect calculations you changed your
mind and just wondered
why
what your opinion is now now you know
it's gonna
the figures are much higher than you
originally
do you still not do you still feel it
should be approved
based on 2 million kilograms of carbon
yeah thank you castle um
initially i did
object we've got to stop burning fossil
fuels that's as simple as that
eventually but
because of this transition to a
decarbonized grid the applicant
provided sufficient evidence that i felt
it's a necessary evil should be put that
way
if
the grid decarbonised quicker
if we get more renewables on stream if
we can store the energy that they supply
then this unit won't run
simple as that so
yeah there is a reliance that we will
achieve this by
2050 but hopefully it'll be a long time
before then
and this actual unit has got a design
life for 20 to 25 years
so that was the reason for my
consideration just to clarify the
um
co2 emissions side of things
each hour that this unit will run
and it may not run for two and a half
thousand
hours a year each out this unit does run
it
um consumes the equivalent of a
gas consumption of two houses per year
so that's each hour
so that's the annual consumption of two
houses
every hour every hour but it is only
going to run at certain times of the
year when there is demand and say if the
wind is blowing and
we've got sufficient capacity from other
generating sources it won't run
um
i'm sure that will correct me but they
get paid for it just to be on standby
not being used not burning gas anyway
but they may get a little bit extra if
it runs but if nashville doesn't want it
to run because it's got sufficient
capacity elsewhere it won't run
right but we can't actually say hera how
much it's going to run so we don't know
what the peak
could be less could be more except that
maximum two and a half thousand
a year
the other issue is is regulated by the
environment agency because it's a and
it's an environmental permit because of
the nature of what does and they will
stipulate the running hours as well
thank you
thank you you want to
thank you chair
what happens after 20 to 25 years do we
still have that sitting there
or do they take it down or
um the the operation is fully reversible
so we would put on a condition that when
it comes to the end of its useful life
the
site will be cleared and returned to
its former condition
cancer beer
thank you mr chairman uh could you just
confirm or clarify you did say 22
000 um
properties could benefit from this
uh if um if we needed it to run is that
correct uh yes the actual figure is 22
909 is the figure given to us there are
23. yes well we've all read the scary
headlines of running electricity in the
future so this is obviously something
that would be welcomed if it was needed
at that particular time to bridge the
gap
thank you
questions counselor here please
council mclaren
thank you chair
um linda on page 29 of the presentation
um the reason for the referral to the
committee
was because the head of economy
considers the application to be of a
controversial nature
can you explain to me who that is is it
somebody within deborah district council
or is it somebody outside of the
organization
uh no it's just that it it could um it
has wider than just sites yeah but who
is the head you've said the head of
economy considers this to be of a
controver who is that
sorry becky pardon that's um standard
text it's the the plan the chief
planning officer oh the chief thank you
very much i just needed that clarifying
thank you thank you linda thank you
any more questions to the officers
yeah it might be one for the
sustainability officer but just just so
that i fully understand um
this this
peaking unit is going to supply
potentially uh or bridge the gap
potentially and supply energy into the
grid as a whole
um so it's not exclusively going to
benefit the the residents of baber this
application that's coming into beaver so
i'm just wondering if we've got any data
on um
on on how many outages
we are predicting in the future how many
how many outages we've had particularly
in the sudbury area but perhaps that's
not fair but um
well i'd i think it's i think it's a
i think it's a valid question um
counselor because we we we need to
understand
my understanding is is that this
particular part of the world has got an
excess amount of capacity
just wanted what your comments were on
that
thank you
um yeah tonight i did check with uk
power networks
they
don't experience many blackouts in if
any blackouts in the sudbury area at all
so that was one of the first things i
checked
um and you're quite right um
suffolk as a whole um
we're
mainly an importer of
energy we've got a few
plants that supply energy notably great
platinum from energy from waste and the
nuclear facilities
but apart from that it all goes into the
mix in a national grid and it supplies
the whole country you're quite right in
that respect
yes
well i assume
that
the same shortage or outage of
electricity will apply across the rest
of the country
so to cover the shortfall we'll need
approximately 3000 of these
power stations if you like which seems
an awful lot it doesn't seem an
efficient way of providing
coverage for
um
shortage of electricity for certain
times of the day i would have thought
that's what nuclear power was supposed
to do um
but it seems to me but also by the time
we've built this surely we will or
if we allow this it takes the pressure
off coming up with a solution for
battery power
sorry it's supposed to be a question
isn't it
all right i'll
the question is how many of these are we
planning on building around the country
thank you simon keep it quiet
how many of these are you planning to
build around the country i've got
absolutely no idea what i could say is
that
um
my response i look quite closely at um
renewable farms that are off the east
coast notably anglia one
feeding into boardsee coming across to
brampton and then feeding down to
twinsted which is really close to
sudbury um that is the route that that
is going to take
but
the issue is is that
if you want the lights to stay on at
certain times before those renewables
are fully in operation you've got to
have some standby reserve and this is
what this application is is for
but i can't tell you how many of these
there will be across the country i just
don't know but isn't standby isn't the
bat isn't that battery power isn't that
what's that that's what it's designed
for
uh
there will be some battery power at the
moment the generation of electrons is a
mix it comes from gas it comes from
biomass it comes from coal although it's
been phased out comes from nuclear comes
from energy from waste all of that feeds
into certain batteries uk power network
have got a large battery site at ayden
buzzer and i've visited that that is
primarily for the issues they have in
late and buzzard and that is a huge
battery facility
each
decentralized unit
in the future will probably have some
battery storage and indeed this unit's
got
battery storage built in as well but um
you still need to top that battery up at
times and
yeah
in this case it'll be from gas in other
cases it will be from other sources
all right
my question will move on to public
speakers
i understand we have representative
chilton parish council mr tony foster
sir you have three minutes to address
the committee
children parish council strongly urges
you to refuse permission for this
development as is not sustainable
as three minutes is too short to deal
adequately with 79 documents we ask you
please to read our two letters of
objection as they set out important
issues the description of the estate as
an industrial estate
creates a misleading impression
most of the businesses here are not
industrial and several use the address
of church field business park
planning law requires that decisions are
made in accordance with your development
plan that is the core strategy unless
material considerations require
otherwise
in summary the development is contrary
to policies em02 the m24
this land is allocated for employment
your core strategy is jobs led
but this development creates no local
jobs at all
this land could be used instead for
other employment uses and provide local
jobs no need for this to be on the
specific plot
your policies cs13 to cs15 inclusive are
a set of policies to reduce greenhouse
gases as required by the nwpf which
framework requires the planning system
to contribute to radical reduction
in greenhouse gas emissions
instead to the contrary the generator
will produce substantial emissions using
fossil fuels the development clearly
contravenes these policies for the
reasons explained in our letters
contravention of policy cs13 by itself
is enough to refuse permission
your policy says all new development
will be required to minimize dependence
on fossil fuels
and to make the fullest contribution to
mitigation climate change there is a
name of a net 10 reduction in co2
emissions
this development does the opposite
its noise level will exceed acceptable
levels in sky views offices
why should that business and its workers
have to suffer such intrusion
your authority needs to give great
weight to the desirability of preserving
the grade one church regardless of the
level of harm anticipated
applicants admit harm caused to the
church and to chilton hall
land immediately next to the churchyard
is allocated as a new cemetery to serve
sudbury
the noise air and dust pollution that is
admitted this development will cause is
incompatible with that use
such will adversely affect the adjacent
public footpath
there are an additional 85 individual
objectives to this proposal
they expect your authority to live up to
its stated policies on climate change
and to the declaration you signed up to
if you grant permission today for this
development credibility in your
authority's policies and public
statements on climate change will be
lost we ask you to refuse it
any questions
thanks about it
um thank you i've obviously read the
summary given by the parish council
they seem selective in their use of our
own policies um when it comes to
the use of
em 24
because i'm not quite sure but i'm
pretty certain that the children parish
council objected to the employment site
at churchill road which is the prologue
site
using those very same so it seems
they're being a bit selective with their
use of em 24
for their own advantage or disadvantage
it doesn't seem to be a consistent
message they're giving out
which is slightly confusing for us as we
sit here
well it is a question
are they
are they uh using the
our policies selectively to justify
their objection
and i think the answer
i can't comment on on what was
done before on the prologue site because
it wasn't the parish council at that
time
good morning mr foster um i looked at
your statement
um about the consultation with the
parish council so how often have you met
with the applicants regarding this
application
uh we haven't met
with enzigor
we've just communicated
so there's been no face well it might
have been difficult during the last few
months might no face first contact no
face to face do you think the
conversations were
informative and useful to the parish
council
um
some some of the documents
may have been slightly confusing to us
um
but that's really all i can i can say i
perhaps would have been more helpful for
somebody to explain some of the detail
would it
yes it might have been
might have been wise after the event yes
thank you very much mr costa thank you
chair
any more question
sure
yeah i'd just like to ask um
do parish or chilton parish council do
do you accept that i hear what you're
saying so that there are 80 objections
um however
as far as the statutory consultations
are concerned we've got no objection
from the environmental agency natural
england heritage environmental health
um and historic england
chose to offer no comment
so they are statutory consultees um
do you accept
uh
their position as a parish council
uh yes i do accept their position but
the 80 odd
people who objected live there and their
lives will be affected possibly if this
um development goes ahead
we oh sorry
um the 80 odd objections were these in
letter form or was this a petition or
did they all
contact chilton parish council or did
they contact the district council
couldn't you just explain please
as i understand it most of them were
written objections
um forwarded to the to the planning
committee
we didn't have any um demonstrations or
anything like that in churchville road
yes i can confirm we had 84
separate objections although some of
those might have been duplications
that was submitted direct to the
planning application via the website
okay thank you very much mr poster
moving on we have an objector
mr robert lindsay you have three minutes
to address the committee
thank you chair
um
yes
the the last speaker mentioned
credibility credibility of the council
and credibility of the officer reports
um i do think i i'm glad that
mr chisnell has
corrected himself but i do think
um
[Music]
it does lay open to the question of
credibility of this the the ground to
refusal
when we should get the figures so badly
wrong
that uh i mean
the initial statement
said that um
you know the the the effectively the
this gas power plant was so efficient
it's most efficient they've invented the
most efficient gas station in the world
because initially the statement from
said that uh
it would be
the equivalent of
i think it was
the the same amount of gas consumed
by two houses
two domestic dwellings in a year
that's how much this gas power station
would consume and that went into the
body of the report from your from your
officer it's totally incorrect i'm glad
mr chisnell's corrected it
the actual amount from the report if you
it's not very clear i have to admit in
the report from the from the developer
but the actual amount it
that that that this this fossil fuel
power station will burn
as much gas in an hour
as one domestic dwelling does in a year
what you're talking about is 2.2 million
tons of carbon dioxide
what does that mean 2.2 million tons is
that a lot or a little it's a lot the
amount that
it's 10
nearly 10
of the emissions from all the houses
in weber
all the heating for all the houses in
baber
so it's adding every year for 25 years
if it's going at the maximum rate
another 10 to the carbon emissions in
this district
so
the other the other aspect i wanted to
tackle was that the idea that this is a
low carbon technology i mean 2.2 million
tons every year tells you this is not a
low carbon technology now and however
the developer i know they've made some
semantic twists and turns looking at the
white paper
but i i promise you i've i've gone
through that last night with a fine
tooth comb i can't find a single mention
where it's expressly says that a
gas-fired
pika plant
is an essential part of the mix or that
it's low carbon we really must
kill that one off now this is not a low
carbon technology and any attempt to
call it as such
is is simply an attempt by the gas
industry to keep going longer than they
need to
um why are we relying on a and a white
paper which is just government thought
at the moment it's already outdated the
technology is moving so fast
these government thoughts are going to
change very quickly and they are
changing
and the direction of travel is phase out
gas
quicker than this
you're well over your three minutes okay
i just finished my sentence if we if we
can because i haven't talked to ugly
you've had you've had the time can i
just finish my sentence so that so um it
makes sense to people how long to finish
your scene at 30 seconds
if if we if we commit to approving this
we're we're
committing uh to getting the the grid
uh dependent on fossil fuel for the next
25 years
um that's not low carbon thank you thank
you
any questions for mr lindsey
closer
uh
jason
robert um the officers just said that
this if you've got to look at the bigger
picture to say that gas this gas
technology is a low carbon technology
so charlotte have you not got a look at
the bigger picture for this
um
what's going on
it's uh
can you hear me all right yeah
um
yeah
yeah yeah of course you've got to look
at the bigger picture and the bigger
picture as i said
is that technology is moving really fast
uh already we've got
at least three applications that i'm
aware of in suffolk of solar farms with
batteries uh and that these are
applications in the office that that you
know the same as this one and they'll
have they they'll do exactly the same as
a gas peaking plant but at zero carbon
they'll supply energy to the grid at
peak times
and
and
already in california two years ago um
they've that the california authorities
told edison power to rip out the gas
peaker plants and replace them with
batteries because of the the carbon
effect and the batteries do just as good
a job but at lower uh with with zero
carbon emissions uh there's also thank
you i think you answered
okay well i was going to look at the
picture i'm just
do you have any more questions
okay any more questions to the objective
thank you very much mr lindsey
we do not have a supporter so now i'll
ask the agent robert gandy to address us
you have three minutes to address the
committee mr mr chairman just to say
it's not it's not wrong to be generous
in speak with people speaking but i know
you'll give the same generosity to the
applicant same to everybody
good morning the need to reduce carbon
emissions to address the impact of
climate change is well documented as is
the uk's ever increasing demand for
energy
the government's 2020 energy white paper
powering our net zero future sets out
the objective of the uk achieving net
zero carbon emissions by 2050 stating
gas peaking facilities shall continue to
have a critical role to play in the
medium turn in the energy uk
energy market
until fully renewable sources are
developed
the proposed standby energy facility
will generate electricity during peak
demand periods in the area when called
upon by the national grid ensuring there
is no drop in service to the consumer
a wholly battery storage facility was
not an option in the locality as the
network parameters are not suitable
paragraph 152 of the mppf states it is
very important for the planning system
to support the desired transition to a
low-carbon future and the energy output
proposed by this application would help
to address this target as larger power
stations are decommissioned and fully
sustainable forms of energy production
are utilized
we welcome the council's planning
department's recommending approval for
the application which is fully compliant
with both national and local policy
requirements all statutory consultants
support the application with conditions
applied where necessary which the
applicant is willing to accept part one
of the new barber local plan core
strategy and apologies policies policy
cs13 renewable and low carb energy
specifically encourages the delivery of
low and zero carbon technologies
whilst there have been objections to the
scheme robust technical reports and
further submissions have demonstrated
to the satisfaction of the council
statutory consultees that the
development will have no adverse effects
upon the local landscape environment or
community and is considered wholly
acceptable with regard to material
considerations the site is a vacant plot
set within an industrial park
local plans are not able to designate
sites for this use so employment sites
present the best option where they are
available the government asks local
authorities to show flexibility over
proposals for standby energy where there
are suitable grid connections
a small amount of gas peaking power
supports a much larger amount of
renewable solar and wind energy which
rely on standby supplies to support
output when they can't produce power
there can be no transition to renewables
without peaking and storage
in accordance with the mppf paragraph
158b which states that applicants
applications for renewable and low
carbon development should be approved by
local authorities its impacts are or can
be made acceptable we respectfully
request that the council support the
officer recommendation and approve the
application
um yeah thank you jeff
could you um
could you tell us with regards to
technology so
my understanding is this this is an
interim measure so as as green and
renewables um uh take over and as they
become more commonplace
um
is there
any availability or opportunity for this
peaking plant to be converted to say for
example hydrogen at some point in the
future if that facility before if that
i think potentially but if i may pass it
on to um jack who's come from balanced
power who's the expert in the field
super thank you i'm sorry
thank you councillor um there is
opportunity in the future to to look at
converting these sorts of technologies
into hydrogen and it's something that is
ongoing um
as we speak we've been in touch with a
lot of different companies with regard
to that effect
um it's early days but it's definitely
something that can be looked at and if
possible will be implemented
the gas engines as they stand can
tolerate a certain level of hydrogen at
the moment without a complete
restructure of the engine themselves
so until that point where they can be
fully converted and
you know they can't at the moment but
it's definitely a possibility in the
future a hundred percent
you have a question for the
applicant
yes i do have a question chair
and the question is
why this site
i believe the uh briefing note that we
supplied to the councillors um showed
that there was um
issues with other
locations to get onto the grid and this
was the
again jack will probably um confirm but
i presume that the reason for that was
this was the only suitable connection to
the grid that could take the output
required
yeah if i may add um
when we look for these potential sites
it's obviously heavily reliant on a grid
connection being close by otherwise it
just becomes completely unviable at all
you have to be within a certain range to
the to the point of connection
and
in doing so we obviously try to look for
areas that are brownfield we don't want
to take up any greenfield land and that
was open up impacts to visuals and stuff
like that so we we do focus our
attention on
sites that are close to the point of
connection but also within industrial
areas and they may fall within
employment areas
um which may seem conscious of the fact
that
you know it's operated remotely but
geographically speaking the area we've
chosen as opposed to the wider area that
this industrial estate seemed a lot more
practical and reasonable to use
council baron you heard a question
uh yeah i have are these
engines turbines or internal questions
these are the internal combustion
yeah
thanks for hold
yeah how many
hours in any one given day do you
anticipate the plant operating i'm
conscious of the location
and obviously it's all very well having
reports
uh
comparing
decibels during a working day on the
estate
but what sort of noise will there be
once the industrial estate is closed
down in the evening and how far do you
anticipate that noise travelling to
residential areas not too far away
so thank you councillor the
the noise anticipated from the
development itself and obviously we
accompanied this application with an
in-depth knowledge report which and an
addendum which concluded that
with the mitigation
applied there was only a basically a one
decibel increase which isn't even
perceptible um
given
given that um
the actual noise itself
is quite a minimal increase they
actually determined that the background
noise levels were quite um
if not just a little bit higher than
what the facility would would produce
and adding that to the background noise
would only result in a one decibel
increase and it definitely shows that
the residential dwellings nearby can't
even perceive it
council home how many hours in a day
would the plant operate
sorry um
typically these facilities won't run you
know we don't want to be running the
plan or national grid doesn't want to be
running the plan uh times of low demand
so the high demand hours as
the case officer rightly says is those
early hours of the morning so um
sort of eight til
half seven till half nine that's the
morning sort of peak demand and the peak
demand in the evening is once you know
um the typical work day is over so it's
sort of about half four
um
maybe to half six seven o'clock
outside that there is absolutely no
reason why
unless an emergency um should come about
from national grid that the facility
should be running outside of those hours
and it's it's unpractical to do so
unless it emerges
mr jameson
because uh based on that because you're
a peaking plant you can't guarantee win
the peaks or how many hours you're gonna
use so
how do you guarantee that you're only
going to use it 2 500
hours
a year
um
we build in 2 500 hours as a maximum
and based on uh you know to make to in
order to make the facility work
and there has to be a sort of
threshold um you know to to run the plan
it does work without the threshold but
we want to be seen to not overcome bust
gas unnecessarily so there's a cap at
2500 hours and it is regulated by mcpd
which is the permit required to run
these plants in accordance with the
environment and so
in essence as the case officer said 50
of the time
is expected but as yeah we can't
guarantee peaks and troughs but if you
look at historical graphs of peak
demands it is during those hours
so even
percent of the demand you're still
looking at based on your
briefing note 1.1 million kilograms of
carbon
a year
is that right
uh yes roughly
about 10 or
the residential
heating carbon that was in this area
so about five percent sorry increase
yeah what was the question your carbon
in your report says the carbon for room
from residential in the council area is
24
million kilograms so
that would be about a five percent
increase is that right
on those calculations
okay thanks
yeah final question for me can i just
clarify um
so this peaking plant does it does it
spark into life when called upon or is
it specific predetermined times i mean
will it will it be going off every
morning between 7 30 and 9 o'clock
no it's when called upon
it's one called
that's a beer
thank you the officers said and i think
you did as well that there was a this
has a role to play
um and it's going to serve 22 nearly 23
000 people
um but the objector said this would only
be a small drop in the ocean you need
lots of these to really make a great
difference so um
what's your view of this i mean this is
necessary to help try and keep the
lights on i assume and um you it you've
done everything low carbon
and that so what should be on that
please when we approach these sorts of
sites
we're all about helping facilitate the
uk becoming at zero by 2050 that's all
our main objective is and you have to
take each site on its own merits because
the the infrastructure that the national
grid have in place at these you know
points of connection
determines the technology that you can
implement in each area and if the
infrastructure in in those specific
points of connection can't facilitate
the import to a battery
it can only export the energy which is
in this case what we're trying to do we
did look at battery in the first
instance but the parameters involved
with the
uk power networks opera sudbury primary
couldn't facilitate that that battery
and so we have implemented what we could
implement on the battery side
but um in this instance it was only an
export
and
we deem it low carbon as in the wider
picture of of the energy mix and you
know as you say that batteries do
provide this this sort of um facility
and need and requirement
um
but it's not
you can't implement it everywhere due to
the parameters involved
you know the electrical parameters
involved with voltage swings and stuff
for the the primary substations it's
very difficult so where we can we will
definitely do battery but we would
rather be shown to do something and
solve the climate emergency through
these means and do nothing at all
thank you mr chairman um
come back to the the point as to why you
you say that you want to put them on
brownfield sites where possible
and that they have to be within a
certain distance of suitable connections
to the grid
why did you pick on sudbury when the
whole area doesn't seem to have a
problem with power
outages or problems with supply
when perhaps it could have been more
suitably put somewhere close to
an area that does have problems because
obviously any connection to the grid
means losses
in terms of uh transmission losses so
the the output may be for 22 000 or
sorry 23 000 homes
for an hour
but
when you take into losses into account
it's probably drops down quite
considerably so why not put it nearer to
somewhere where it has problems rather
than in an area where it doesn't have
problems
i mean what the overall strategy of
decarbonizing
the the energy
infrastructure in the uk is about
decentralizing that energy
energy infrastructure and so by
implementing these um sorts of
facilities whether that be battery or
whether that be gas peaking at each
individual point of connection across
the uk you are enabling larger gas
facilities to come offline which over
produce electricity because of those
transmission losses
so
where where capacity is available at
each substation
there is an opportunity to provide
energy either on a low carbon or zero
carbon scale which could benefit the
area or the the you know the rough areas
around that that and substation so you
have to
it's really about
not shifting the problem elsewhere you
have to in order for this to work at a
speed which is necessary for 2050 you
have to accommodate each point of
connection as and when that capacity is
there because
as i said on this specific occasion
battery wasn't available so we had to
revert to gas which we you know we
ideally don't like to do but it is also
recognized as a means
um to facilitate in this speed to a net
zero future
haven't we got one of these uh
generators on our airfield
didn't we wasn't that approved some time
ago
i just wanted to know um are you aware
of that um how much that's used
and would and wouldn't that be a natural
place for expansion rather than a new
site
i couldn't really comment on on that
application i'm not too involved in that
at all and but
as i said before
if you if you look at those types of
facilities that means of expansion and
you'd rather put them in those sorts of
places where precedence has been set for
them
the energy that is what if you know
there's an example where sudbury
requires the energy or the immediate
areas around sudbury require the
electricity from that facility
um
there'll be losses of that electricity
coming from that facility it's all about
the interconnectivity of the network and
focusing
generation in one place
isn't decentralizing the
the network it's
centralizing it in a way which isn't the
objectives of what the government is
setting out to do
no more
then thank you very much
moving on um
we have
board member councillor mabry has given
her apologies and provided a statement
which i will now ask the government
officer to read out on her behalf
i am not in favour of this development
the idea of a gas driven generator to
produce electricity when all fossil
fuels are being discouraged from use by
all national and local councils eco
groups and other informed avenues is
abhorrent assigning the generator to
increase the amount of electricity for
our sudbury area raises concerns in
several several areas
why do we need it
if it is to increase electricity to
supply due to demand why has uk power
networks not facilitated a permanent
supply when there are a statutory
consultae
why has baby district council not liaise
with uk power networks to ascertain that
their resources will fulfill demand in a
sustainable and permanent manner
if some of the answers to my questions
above relate to the proposed development
of chilton woods and other associated
local new developments at long melford
acton great cournade etc i question the
far detailed analysis of planning of
both our council and that of all
utilities
if there are not enough resources
planning should not be accepted
bdc may need to make a stand and say no
no to unsustainable development note of
fossil fuels for use whatever reason no
to industrial unit that would of not
offer employment no to this development
my learned colleagues will give policies
which this development does not meet
they will state the emerging joint local
plan they may perhaps think oh well
mid-southwest have such a generator at
eye so what
officers may think it will not be used
often but what is missing here is the
issue of climate change of its effects
on our local residents our natural
wildlife i know dormice have disappeared
from hedgerows at the children woods
site our local fauna and flora as well
as our businesses adjacent to some
fossil eating noisy piece of machinery
if a gas generator is needed for
increased electricity demand and
something is seriously wrong with the
development ethics of our district i
urge members of the planning committee
to refuse this application
thank you
we also have the other ward member
present
cancer arthi
you having trouble with the microphone
that one is on move
[Music]
[Applause]
you have five minutes cancel off yeah i
won't take that long thanks very much um
yeah during the um the progress of the
application i have of course spoken to
linda bacon the case officer um and um
given everything that's been said and in
the report um i accept that there may
well be a case for
peak power plants of some sort
in the network
but i found myself asking um two
questions
one is should this type of gas-powered
electricity generation
be allowed at all
paragraph 4.5 of your report
extracts from the white paper
which talks about low carbon options
for peaking capacity
as being hydrogen and storage and one
presumes that by storage they probably
mean battery storage
so
i looked at the nppf
um
and
at paragraph 152 it says the planning
system should support the transition to
a low carbon future
in a changing climate and it should help
to shape places in ways that contribute
to radical reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions
minimize vulnerability and improve
resilience
encourage the reuse of existing
resources
and support
renewable and low carbon energy and
associated infrastructure
so whilst it doesn't address what you
shouldn't support it says what you
should support
and so the flip side must be that you
should not support
non-renewable
and high carbon fossil fuel uses
the second question i found myself
looking at is
should it be here
and i think one of the councillors has
already asked that question it's close
to the graveyard of a grade one listed
church
and in the glossary to the nppf
it says
about the setting of a heritage asset
it says
the surroundings in which a heritage
asset is experienced constitute the
setting
its extent is not fixed and may change
as the asset and its surroundings evolve
elements of a setting may make a
positive or negative contribution to the
significance of an asset
and then the important bit it says
may affect the ability to appreciate
that significance okay so we're not
talking just about the asset we're
talking about the appreciation
of that asset
so
i think really what i'm doing is asking
you to ask yourselves a couple of
questions
um
this type of plant be
approved at all is it in terms of
carbon
is it a little bit like buying yourself
a diesel generator to charge your
electric car
secondly
if you were standing in the graveyard of
chilton church maybe quietly
contemplating either in the existing
graveyard or the proposed extension to
the graveyard
would your appreciation of the grade one
listed church and its surroundings
be affected by a generator kicking in
behind you
and i suggest it probably would
so
one last
comment question which i thought of
during the previous questions
if this is to provide for when the wind
doesn't blow and the sun doesn't shine
which apparently these peaking plants
are
why are they not located near where
the wind blows and
there are generators or near to where
the sun shines and there are generators
because if it's for the lack of wind or
sun
then the obvious place to tap into the
network is
where the wind and the sun come from so
you would expect this sort of plant to
be beside a wind farm or a solar farm is
what i'm
saying thank you
thank you
any questions for councillor arthur
and severe i just asked him where do you
expect i can understand the wind you can
put up
near the edges coast or something but
where do you expect the sun come from i
mean
solar power generated on solar farms i'm
not suggesting that the council has
roofs that have solar panels should have
a tiny gas peaking plant right beside
them
thanks to barrett um just the question
is um i think the key word is transition
which you mentioned
it's a transition so that's that's to me
the key
it's not about anything else it's
transition um from
from a high carbon output of electricity
to a low carbon so would you not agree
that um that my question i suppose to
you is it's transition really isn't it
a new state transition it's not about a
permanent situation it's about a
transition from it
to a low carbon yeah well the answer to
the question if there is a question is
this is addressed in the white paper
and i quoted from it earlier on and the
government says that the transition
should be accommodated by hydrogen and
storage
yeah it doesn't talk about accommodating
with gas it's transition
i would say okay
[Applause]
parker questions
um thank you counselor um i'm
just a bit confused i mean obviously
this site is being proposed on an
industrial estate on and it is an
employment site so
um your reticence around its effects to
um to to the heritage asset which is
which is perfectly valid that's fine but
it is it is explained in the report it
is um uh explained away in the report as
well but but but surely by definition if
um if you object to that then then
nothing could come forward on this on
this site is do you agree with that
no no not really
i mean if you look at the existing uses
um on the estate
let's say you were to drive down
churchfield road at two o'clock in the
morning
you wouldn't find very many of those
uses in operation um so um and certainly
you wouldn't find noisy uses in in
operation if this were were to be um for
a 20 or 25 year period which is what's
being talked about one would imagine
that in
10 years time
a lot of people will have electric
vehicles and they'll be charging at
night it may well be that the peak
period is no longer 7 30 to 9 30 in the
morning it may well be that these plants
are kicking in at
you know seven in the evening
two in the morning
and
in that regard i've mentioned the effect
on the church
but um i don't know if a
plan could be put up but there are of
course residences not that far
across the field
which
which would be affected by that as well
as i'd correct
the cabinet member for planning that um
actually at 2 2 30 in the morning
churchill road is busy because it has
the post office facility there and if he
had gone down there at 2 30 more he
would see the post office is actually
working
it's not a particularly noise generating
years
thank you
any more questions for counselor arthur
nope thank you very much council arti
right
will now open the item up to debate
who would like to kick off
councillor parker would just beat you
too okay
i'm looking at cancer parker as well
i've i've got this wide island
just faster
quicker off the mark
i've i've almost forgotten here now what
i was going to say i'm just distracted
but
no what i was going to say um chair is
um and i think we can have quite an
expensive debate on this um i think but
but what i think is really important um
is
we've got this conflict between what
what what it is that we're deciding here
what we're not deciding is the future of
um of renewable energy as um as baba
district council planning committee um
what what i think that we've got to
always bear in mind um is that what
we're deciding here is whether the the
use of the land that's being proposed is
is um is suitable and appropriate that
that i think is what we're here to
to undertake this morning rather than
the future of renewable energy can we
just have that confirmed
or otherwise
yeah so um obviously the concern i think
the main concern of this
for this site is
what impact it has on its neighbours in
terms of noise that clearly is the only
thing as far as i can see
is the main
deficit
of this site if we're looking at a
planning consideration as opposed to the
bigger debate of where we're going with
our council the park has issued so i've
just looked at where it's positioned
and i'm trying to work out where we have
residential housing
and as far as i can work out for my
knowledge of this which is pretty
extensive
we have no
residential housing
until we hit welding field
to one side
we have residential housing
going towards uh
which is now church uh church from well
the end of churchill road where the the
medical center is and then past that we
then have residential house which is at
least half a
mile i think half a mile
to the to the south or to the bottom we
have industrial units and we also have
uh across northern road we have nestle
purina
who are a 24-hour operation and they are
closer to the residential houses
so if we take all that into
consideration if you say there's a one
decibel increase in the ambient noise
when they're operating
i'm just
to me it doesn't seem like there is an
issue regarding the
environmental impact
if that's my
if i'm correct in my
where i'm looking at the people
so as a planning consideration and which
is a material consideration
that's what we need to be looking at and
i don't think there is any material
consideration that would be on the
environmental and that's clearly come up
with the reports we've had
of any uh detriment to the surrounding
area
so that's just my observation on that
one
i should be you won't
join in
can't afford
i would like to know the answer to
councillor parker's a question that he
put forward to the officer because i
think it's quite relevant we are here to
go
would you like uh but could you
emphasize the question again
well if if
if i need to chair but i mean
it was really just raising the question
are we here to determine uh the the the
land and the appropriate or the
appropriate use of the land uh rather
than the future of
renewables
but i'll get the opposite
well broadly speaking but i think we've
got to consider well we've got to gently
unpack what it is that this proposal is
but also
what it does and why and to that extent
it is important and consider what role
it plays bearing in mind that obviously
we do have policies that relate to
moving to a to a low carbon economy in
future
um just in terms of the the national
planning policy framework because we
touched on the white paper which is a
material consideration the framework
itself we've already looked at paragraph
152 but not necessarily the final part
of that policy which is about supporting
um renewable and low carbon energy and
its associated infrastructure and that's
effectively what what this is
which is why when if you were to look at
this in isolation and i think yes on
first blush that's why there's a tension
there with our policies starting with
the development plan because ultimately
this is something that is burning a
fossil fuel
but when you look at that bigger picture
the fact is that this is something that
is there to support that transition to
moving to a low-carbon future and it's
in that respect that that tension falls
away
um
and wide accords with both the
development plan and national
planning policy in in offices view and
related to that of course this is about
energy security as as we've touched on
you know their will you know energy
renewable energy its time has come but
nevertheless that it's still not quite
there infrastructurally to enable us to
rely upon it 24 hours a day
can answer both of you
well i think i'll go back to my original
question which is why here
why should
we allow that
development on that particular site
it may be convenient for the applicant
but i can't say it's particularly
convenient for sudbury it's uh it's
supposed to be an employment site and
it's going to generate no employment
it's not needed for local use
it's going to chuck out a whole pile of
carbon which is not particularly good
for the climate
it's right next to a grade one listed
heritage site which is not good for that
and we always say that planning
applications are determined on a balance
of kind of good versus evil
in this case
i can't see any reason for allowing this
particular application to go ahead
it's just its only benefit for this site
is it's convenient
well i'm sorry but convenience doesn't
really count for a great deal when you
take all the other negative aspects into
account so on balance i think i'm
against it
thank you
um
i'm not very technical so a lot of this
is way beyond me
but the bottom line is we are here to
represent
residents and
support them
and this is about who's going to benefit
for the
installation of this
site and
whatever the future holds i think
at the moment that is not for
consideration in terms of environmental
changes
but who who are going to benefit
and there's going to be a lot of benefit
around suffering and surrounding areas i
would have thought of and as a member of
the planning committee i feel very
strongly about what residents benefit
from when we make decisions
so that's my comment
i hadn't been up all over council there
you pick up um thank you mr chairman yes
well i want to echo what my colleague
pencil of the clowns just said i mean
it's definitely there's a role to play
uh 23 000 people um could have their
likes kept on as a result of this we
don't know
but uh certainly to suggest that because
it may not affect the people in babel i
think is a bit wishful thinking um i i
think anything to do to help uh keep the
lights on throughout the country
we should take part in hopefully it
won't be used as much this is what um
we've been told that there are
fins in play which will
come in and affect this
hopefully we will get to
the 2050 and all these other
renewable energies will come on board
and
keep
the lights on
it is low carbon and
i really think we're making very hard
work of this mr chairman and i'm quite
prepared to propose
the officer's recommendation and in this
case i'll ask for a second to please
and you have one at the end
we
refer to this as a low carbon it's not
it's gas it's a fossil fuel
it's going to kick out um based on the
figures going to kick out two million
kilograms of
carbon which is equivalent to
nearly 10 of the residential heating we
put out already and we've already
declared the climate emergency this
council yet we're going to
agree potentially agree
uh a planning application
that
significantly increases our carbon
we
need to stop using fossil fuel fuels now
so
um as came out in the ipcc report
recently
and um
i can't see that it's going to benefit
any anyone in sudbury and and i would
like to propose that we actually refuse
this
cancer hulk do you want to
yeah thank you um
i've got a problem with the plant i've
got a problem with the type of plant i
think it's a necessary evil for the
times we live in and it's there to
fill in the gap until we do come on to
more sustainable
forms of energy
um it's the location which i do have a
slight issue with and it's been referred
to a one decibel
uh rise in in noise level i'd like to
ask our environmental health
officer who's here in the report on page
34 it mentions plus 10 decibel
above the background level and
i'd just like some clarification as to
whether we're talking about one decibel
or we're talking about 10 decibels
because my concern is to the
west i would say of the site where
there's offices
i think
the images we've seen today are quite
ugly and there's obviously
a concern read the noise levels i've
mentioned noise possibility in the
evenings and night times
um but can i just have clarification on
i think it's one two three four fours
about the fifth paragraph down it
mentions a plus 10 decibel
above the background level so i'm
assuming that is the background level
of the industrial state on a normal day
and then when the plant kicks in it's a
10 decibel gain on top of that can just
someone confirm that
i'm sorry i know i'm the representative
here from environmental health but i
wasn't the person that did that
calculation so
um i didn't know about that plus 10 but
i'm sorry could you so yeah i haven't
got the papers so um could you say about
place 34.
oh thank you thank you
thank you
i just think that overall that the noise
impact is the main concern for me for
the for the employment business or the
on-site raw mail is irrelevant as far as
i'm concerned that the officers adjacent
to the site as i say to the west of this
may have issues with that noise level
and also i still don't think we've had a
clear answer when potentially the
generator could run
if we can be guaranteed it won't run
between 10 pm and
6 a.m then i
but
you know
the officers there only work between
seven in the morning till six at night
so i just wanna clarification on the
noise
sorry can i uh uh respond now um
yeah the plus
ten to be above the ground level is
referring to bs4142
which is the um
standard that's applied at
the playing stage for this
the um
officer who who dealt with the noise
side did seek further
recommendations or suggestions from the
applicant and that's where the 1db came
in
um
so i'm a little bit confused as to why
they're that they're saying that it
could be plus 10 db i didn't understand
that was the case
can we get some clarification
i i can have a go at answering i mean
the the case officer
has obviously been in extensive dialogue
with with the environmental health
officer on this um as far as i'm reading
from the papers the 10 decibel
adjustment is actually in terms of the
sensitivity because that's allowing for
should that should it be a hot day the
offices
will open their window and therefore
they're looking for a
further decrease in terms of the noise
levels as they hit that building should
the with the windows be open so it makes
them more sensitive to noise by
10 decibels
which is why
a lower
out a lower reading
or exceedance level is required at that
boundary
and that's something that the
um the applicants are confident they can
achieve through mitigation mitigatory
measures such as acoustic fences and
fencing and that's something that's been
considered
by the environmental health officer and
will be secured by condition
to ensure that the amenity afforded to
the occupiers of the office building can
be
adequately safeguarded
thank you
pastor hinton you are
thank you mr chairman um well first of
all if you
remember i'd like to um concur with what
counselor busby says in terms of his um
assessment of need etcetera if we
remember in the not too distant past
there was a lightning strike on a
wind farm in yorkshire
which effectively blew up a gas turbine
power station in bedfordshire which
blacked out half of ipswich
so
as you can see the interconnection of
the grid is quite extensive and this is
why i fail to see
why there is a necessity for this
relatively small
electricity generating facility
to be put in the on the outskirts of
sudbury where there has been no
instances of blackouts in the past
uh caused by over over uh lack of
facility of lack of
generating
capacity um and also when we look at
what is going to happen in the next few
years we're going to see
module and nuclear plants put up which
are zero going to be zero carbon
output on
uh plants um which will
more than um suffice for any increase in
capacity that the grid might need
and also if we just also just to
properly point out to councillor beer
that
he's made a big thing about the 23 000
homes getting their electricity for an
hour
so if you're watching a program on the
television that's longer than an hour
i'm afraid you've missed it
because it will black out on you halfway
through
so it's only for one hour based on using
0.33 kilowatts and i think if you turn
your washing machine on you'll probably
use up somewhere around about that
amount of uh electricity
so
you can either have your television on
you can put your washing machine on or
you can put the kettle on you know one
or two you can't do all and it's only
going to last the facility will only be
there for an hour
so it's it's all a bit
borderline in terms of the actual output
from this plant
and the fact that it doesn't comply with
our sustainability policies and that's
what we're here to talk about we're here
to talk about policies rather than
thoughts
or anything else
and i would like to agree with
councillor jameson that we should in
actual fact be refusing this as it's
contrary to cs15
well just just really to um to take a
contra view on that um but but not
entirely you see
as our officer
said to us earlier there is there is a
clear conflict with with this with this
proposal and this is the issue because
we
we're committed to being zero uh carbon
by by 2030 and yet here we are
um you know with this proposal the
problem
of course is that all of us
every single one of us here is going to
have an increasing demand on electricity
not a decrease in demand so actually
that we need to wean ourselves off of
electricity is is the real issue but of
course we're not going to do that so if
we accept that we we're going to have
more electricity it's all well and good
saying that you know we can't have these
plants but but what then um
you know whole questions about the
lights going out etc so unfortunately
for for me as as i sit here at the
moment as much as i absolutely
understand all of the arguments being
being put forward as to why we shouldn't
do this um i haven't heard a single
thing that that's um explaining
describing perhaps one of my colleagues
could um explain to us what what an
alternative um is that's before us
you know
we're not being asked to do nothing
we're being asked to take a decision so
that's all i'll say thanks jeff
anyone else wish to say anything before
we take the
council jameson
um just um councillor mclaren
she's looking at this in benefits of the
people would sudbury but i can't see any
benefits to the people of sudbury
there's no employment there's increase
in noise it's going to affect the
heritage site of the
church so
and the electricity that may be
generated is going into the grid it's
not dedicated to the people of sudbury
so i don't see
any benefits to the people of sudbury
if we agree this
thank you
coach the beer you are could i just ask
where the where do we get our
electricity from the national grid thank
you
thank you counselor basically you want
to make well partly to answer uh council
parker's question about what's the
alternative well
we've got facing us uh four solar farm
applications coming forward we've got
offshore wind coming out of well say
coming out of our areas which is not
physically possible but
um
all coming onshore to the uh the baber
mid suffolk area we've got an energy
from waste site we've got battery
storage in the same area i think
baba and mid-suffolk are doing more than
their fair share in terms of energy
production and energy distribution i
don't think we need to go particularly
for one
gas
fired
generator
um yeah i take on board what uh council
bus was saying about the solar farms but
of course one of the things you can't do
you can't eat electricity so the more
agricultural land that we take out of
use and make electricity then there's a
danger that we actually reduce the
amount of food that we're producing so
as much as we'd like to eat electricity
it doesn't actually sustain us so
there's a danger the big solar farms
although they're quite handy and they're
quite good actually do mean there's a
reduction in the available and i think
there's a
grade two land is being used which is
not good um it should be lower than that
grade three or whatever but there seems
to be a preference now of going into
higher grade land which is good
agricultural land
that's a danger i think we need to be
aware of that
we have no more
comments no more additions to the debate
then we have a proposal on the table
that we accept the officer's
recommendation can i ask the governor's
officer to organize a vote we're all
okay with that
thank you yes
thank you
members of that vote is now in progress
on your app
thank you chair that is five votes four
and five votes against the application
you should have brought your wife simon
um i vote against the proposal
so proposal is defeated we now have a
proposal for refusal
have you the reasons why
we've reviewed uh based
uh based on our policy cs13 and cs15
which
pros we go for
low carbon
supplies
are we happy with that
we can make something
you've obviously got to factor into
account um
other material considerations such as
national planning policy and guidance
emerging policy and guidance and of
course the benefits of the scheme so i
need to be clear that you've factored
those into account and they don't
offer an alternative direction to that
posed by the development plan which
would appear to be to refuse basically
the mppf as mentioned by accounts raffy
does
also state that we should be
transitioning to a low carbon future
and this is not a low carbon future
that's absolutely fine i'm just being
clear that you're you're taking that
into
taking that into account so that um
in effect um
the wording that i would propose based
on what you've said
is that um
the proposal
comprising a fossil fuel-powered standby
energy generation facility and would not
represent sustainable development
by reason of the environmental harm
occasion by the burning of a fossil fuel
that would increase carbon emissions in
the locality
contrary to policy cs13 and cs15 of the
local plan
and there are no material considerations
that indicate otherwise
yeah along those lines
refusal but of course
if you look at page 32 of the report it
talks about sp 10 climate change lp 21
historic environment
and
lp 25 sustainable construction design
and lp 27 energy sources and
distribution which are all part of the
new draft
joint local plan which does have
significant weight now
you can you can give as much weight to a
material planning consideration as you
see fit that's your judgment i think
officers would probably exercise a
little bit more caution on that
particular point but nevertheless the
emerging policies in the plan which are
currently subject to examination they
will be caught in the balance of the
other material considerations so we
start with the development plan that by
the sounds of
the reasoning of the proposal that's
giving a clear direction to refuse on
account of the principle of this
and then you go to the other material
considerations which
which could include the emerging
plan as well if you feel that that's
inconsistent
with those policies i think um
the only thing i need to flag and
obviously we've already had a proposal
that's failed is that
this is highly likely to go to appeal i
think officers will advise based on
their judgment the likelihood is that we
will be unsuccessful in defending that
appeal and this is not a material
planning consideration but there is a
likelihood of costs being awarded
against the council if we proceed
okay
so i think i think we've so we've got
that council james
yeah you have a proposal and you have a
second year
and you're happy with
very chair i was i was
queering the vote but in fact i missed
you out of the box or i was counting on
how many people
shall i read it again yes please
um
so the proposal comprising a fossil fuel
powered standby energy generation
facility would not represent sustainable
development by reason of the
environmental harm caused by the burning
of a fossil fuel that would increase
carbon emissions in the locality
contrary to policy cs13 and cs15 of the
local plan
the application fails to comply with the
development plan as a whole and there
are no material considerations which
indicate otherwise
you're happy with that country hinting
so we have a proposal
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress
okay
thank you chair that's
five votes four and five votes against
um as i just voted
for the proposal i go before
so we refuse the offer
the application is refused
thank you everyone
right
we take a quick break now
and then there will be no break between
the next two items to get you out
back everyone hope you've all
had sufficient time to get yourselves a
cup of coffee
all right move me on
dc 2100 599 station road car park
station road sudbury suffolk
um
i'll ask owen faires to introduce the
subject to us
good morning members today i'm
presenting an application for full
planning permission
for the erection of free solar
photovoltaic carports with associated
infrastructure
including cabling to the leisure center
battery storage system and five electric
vehicle charging points
the application has been brought forward
to committee as it has been submitted on
behalf of labour district council
so this is an aerial map of sudbury
the site is highlighted in red
it's located to the south of the main
market square of station road sudbury
leisure center is located to the east of
the site with the waitrose supermarket
located to the west
so
this is a closer view for site which
is again highlighted in red with a
ledger center to the east and the retro
supermarket to the west
this is the site location plan
the red line shows the application site
with the blue line showing for land and
ownership of baby district council
in terms of constraints the site is
located outside of the sudbury
conservation area located to the north
west which is shown in purple
to the south side is the style valley's
special landscape area which is shown in
green
and also to the south of the site you
can see a green dashed line which is a
public right of way
so this is the proposed block plan
the soda car ports are located
here
so you can see in blue
so we've got
two carports to the northern boundary
and one more central in the site
the five electric vehicle charging
stations
are located here
to the northern boundary
the battery storage and lockable glass
reinforced plastic housing container are
located in these boxes here
and there's a trench cable routes can be
seen in light blue
along here
so this is the light shows the layout of
the carports the northern the northern
car ports cover the depth of a single
parking bay whilst the central carport
covers the depth of two parking bays
the carports will cover a total number
of 42 parking bays and in total
installation comprises of approximately
291 pv panels
so these are the proposed elevations of
the carports the carports along the
northern barren troop for site covering
a single bay measure approximately 4.1
meters in height
with the central carport covering the
depth of two parking bays measuring a
total height of 4.8 meters
so the following shot slides it shows
some photos of the site
in the bottom left corner of the slide
shows an aerial map of the area with an
arrow showing where the photo was taken
from
for context the northern barren tree for
sight
is
you can see this line of trees here
which makes up for northern boundary
this light shows a view from the access
point into the car park towards the
leisure center
this slide shows the site from the
western boundary again looking towards
the leisure center
this slide shows the site from the north
western corner
um again to point out this row of mature
trees here is the northern boundary for
site
this slide shows the site from the north
eastern corner looking back along
northern boundary towards the waitrose
building
this slide shows site from the eastern
boundary again looking towards the
waitrose building
this shows the location of the battery
electric storage system behind
the lockable gates we can see here
with the lockable glass reinforced
plastic housing container located
approximately here
so to summarize the proposal promotes
sustainable development by providing
renewable energy facilities supporting
the council's aim of becoming carbon
neutral by 2030.
the proposal would not impact the
existing parking provision or layout of
the car park and the proposal would not
result in a detrimental effect on
residential immunity or for surrounding
area and landscape
his
recommendation therefore is the grant
planning permission with the condition
set out within your agenda thank you
uh just uh for clarification the
positioning in the car park um the
application coming forward for the
medical center that is that purely in
the
um
lorry park area
it's uh if you have to get the side off
the layout please um it's above the car
park where the lorries are um
as i say the main leisure center car
park is divided into two um sort of
defined areas yeah there's a there's a
divide between the lorry park and the
area that you're putting these yes there
is um i said i'll pull up the plan just
to
so i can show you that
sorry to be a yes so
the aerial map shows it
so the
so obviously that
yeah so this is the site in question
in this space i think the lorry kind of
parking area is that's the laurel park
is that where the health center is going
i'm not sure i'm afraid
yes i've been advised is yes yeah that's
where it proposes
yeah okay because i know
it's not um
sometimes these things you know get put
in place and then i would hate to think
that we took them take them out and then
there's a development going in
instead
fine thank you for that clarification
thank you
thank you mr chairman um just a quick
point the
solar generation capacity at the leisure
centre is that linked into this system
and secondly
the uprights supporting the pole of the
pv panels where you've got two bays
end on
um is there any allowance made for
extra width to the base to avoid
colliding with those because we don't
want people driving into those and
effectively bringing down the whole
structure
so as i said there should be no change
in the parking provision um i think the
width it shouldn't affect the parking
accessibility at all
um i think it's probably best uh
best advised i think the applicant may
be better advised with regard to
expansion
and the generation
at the medical center i've got the
medical center on my brain there on
the uh
leisure center
but um that's probably better a question
better suited to the applicant
that's linked directly to the leisure
center through um and through via the
battery storage
um and approximately 16 and a half
percent of the leisure center um
energy use can be facilitated by the
solar canopies so there's a
substantial
benefit to the
electricity intake at the leisure center
and in terms of the design features
the previous
work that the council was undertaking in
terms of the high level and more
detailed site feasibility and the
optimal layout does account for vehicle
movements on the site um the actual
structure itself has been specified as a
higher standard than the usual type of
canopy to make extra allowance for it
being in a public setting there's the
there's no net loss of parking bays
there's sufficient space within the
structure um and um we've looked to make
sure all the cabling um and the actual
maneuverability in and out is is the
best that can be
made from that size of system um and
it's it's going to cover about 42 spaces
in the in that area of the leisure
center copper
that's been
could you put that slide up again the
one with the
yeah um
so will there be any trees removed
because you can see there's quite a bit
of shadow over the car
um
no
no landscaping is proposed to be removed
okay no more questions
fine thank you very much joey
ryan moving on
um
we have no public speakers um obviously
you've met the
applicants um
we're here to answer questions
we have no award member
um so i'll open it up
for debate
thanks a bit
oh well kick off i'm very pleased to
hear that we're not losing any car
parking spaces that's certainly a plus
and it's good
for the motors it's time that they had a
fair crack of the weapon um rather than
on being attacked all the time
they are doing their bit mr chairman i
think um
this can only help and it will be
welcomed by them and i am quite happy to
move the officer's recommendation thank
you
thanks for baron second did you make any
comment uh no just happy to go with the
flow on this one
anyone else want to make any comments
plenty
i'd just like to make a
comment if i may on the the
panels above carport
sounds wonderful great for providing
shade as we have all these extreme
weather events with excessive heat etc
so they will keep the cars clean but i
hope they have built to a sufficient
standard to be able to withstand
heavy snowfall uh i know from the
experience in uh
on the continent that uh somebody
sometimes these things are built to a
uh
an ordinary should i say standard and
then you get sudden heavy snowfall
and i can take you to parts of spain for
instance where they used to have loads
of carports for
shielding cars from the sunshine rather
than for energy generation
but they're not there anymore because
they all got flattened by a snow floor
specification is that um
the the actual structure should be able
to withstand exceptional
100-year weather events so that's been
put in as part of the
um the specification the steel frame
itself um it's going to be galvanized
and there's a screw
fix steel system
um which should be um robust enough
the
the contractor um is also going to be
putting in um a significant amount of um
measures in terms of the actual housings
for the um the cabling to make sure that
there's no
access or
issues of of that nature um from either
a vehicle collision or deliberate acts
of vandalism so um as best we can um the
steel frame the hot rod steel frame
structure should be able to withstand
sufficient
um and also the um
on top of the actual pv panels that will
go on there was going to be an extra
sheet as well to support the um the as
you say like snowfall any
any debris that can get on the top or
any actual things that are put on the
top
from from any any vandals or anything
like that we will maintain the pv as
well um as part of a separate contract
the council's looking i think it's march
next year
to
look at the estate management of the pv
including some of the residential and
this will be included in that as well to
make sure that the necessary maintenance
um and also the cctv system for the town
has also been looked at in terms of
coverage to make sure that the um
structure and the the facilities can be
observed through the cctv system
thank you
cancer
yeah um i assume this is going to be
like a fast charge because when the
obviously charges do come in on subway
car parks
they don't be charged
over
it's like a statement
initially the system can support or um
and from from the start but there'll be
five electric vehicle charging points
installed four fast and actually one
rapid and the rapid is the one that can
charge up to eighty percent
um vehicle charging in in about 50
minutes or so so that's a
that's a significant step for
um
and because this is very much a learning
pilot as well
putting this technology in place will
give us a very good opportunity to
actually monitor how the uses
is is uh and the demand is um
is is going forward um and support
similar installations across the
districts as well if
these work out as expected as a as a
significant benefit to the
infrastructure in the district
you have oh you want to ask a question
as well yeah yes uh follow along for
that it's triggered something
does that mean that if
the charge has come in that you've only
got one hour
to park
it could take two or three hours to
charge up
so you'll have to
pay for that as well on top of the
the charging of the or will that all be
in a sort of set deal
yeah or would it be two charges i
suppose i'm saying yeah so so the the
exact um charging mechanism is yet to be
fully determined and it does link into
the council's wider sort of parking
strategy work that's underway as well
but
essentially um
yeah
we we need to we will need to do some
promotion about how
the
vehicle charging points are used in
practice because obviously we want to
generate that turnover particularly the
rapid charging point if it's we don't
want someone parked there all day really
if
we want that churn of people able to use
the the rapid facilities and also
obviously for the income generation
aspect as well
mr chairman if i can come back on that
uh you have a next answer my question i
understand what you're saying um and
that there's this parking review which i
don't know anything about
um but
are we chart will be charging
um after one hour
for
the vehicle being parked there plus the
charging costs of charging the vehicle
what you said
is what could come later yeah if i went
there once you'd put that up and i
plugged in my which i haven't got
electric car um would i be charged for
parking there over one hour and would i
be charged separately then for the
charge yes
yeah yeah that's what
thank you
just one more just one more quick point
as to chairman based on what what
councilman has been saying about charges
etc
um
did we investigate
this location has presumably been been
selected because it's close to the
leisure center and it can be linked to
the leisure center etc did we look at
the possibility of any sort of
partnership agreement with waitrose as
per volkswagen and tesco's where they've
been putting in free charging points
yes we did have a very early
conversation with waitrose about this
but um because of the actual
the optimal scheme that was produced was
really to to maximize the
self-generation impact against the
leisure center this is not a very large
scheme um in terms of 40 days and what
it can actually generate because with
the feasibility study
the constraints of the site and the use
of the site will factor in as well so
on the basis it's quite a small scheme
it was not progressed with waitrose
because we looked at you know the
benefits to the leisure center first and
foremost however
as mentioned this is a learning scheme
potentially it is scalable
and there may be opportunities that
arise from this and indeed from the
apollo medical center work as well which
we've also had some dialogue with um
really to see whether from the outset
that there was a was would there be an
opportunity
to do something joined up not at the
stage we need because we
we we are bound to some external
timelines for the funding we've got
significant amount of uk government
funding to support this so the time
frames weren't really compatible at this
stage but that's not to say that there
might not be opportunities that arise in
the future
okay rojax it will go to the road
prepare if you can prepare the vote
members that vote is now in progress
so
thank you members chair that's 10 votes
for that's unanimous thank you for 10
votes for
right
thank you everyone
moving on we have before us an emergency
item
urgent item which is dc dc2100745
cuckoo hill viewers
um and simon bailey is going to brief us
on the subject
uh thank you chair good afternoon
members thank you thank you luke
this
okay
this
an urgent item added to the agenda with
permission from the chair
the matter refers to the committee's
resolution of the 14th of july
to grant planning commission for over
rise scheme
for plots five and six at the former
slaughterhouse site cuckoo hill viewers
now known as appletree muse
committee resolution of the 14th july
was to grant planning permission for the
revised scheme
uh presented then uh subject to
uh section 106 planning obligation
um with the security of a bond to the
sum of 250 000 pounds
for the council to draw from to complete
the development should the
developer for whatever reason default
we've been advised by the developer that
unfortunately despite their best efforts
they've been unable to secure a bond to
the agreed value
as such they are requesting an amendment
to your resolution of the 14th of july
as set out in the papers before you the
options considered viable included
firstly a cash deposit with the council
secondly
the transfer of title to the two
properties and thirdly a bond
but to a lower value
we've sought council opinion on these
options in order to ensure any risk that
the council is
minimized as much as is reasonably and
foreseeably possible
um having regards to the advice from
council the option put before you today
uh for amendment of the resolution of
the 14th of july involves both the
deposit of cash with the council
and the transfer of title to the
properties
should they develop a default during the
works to the properties
to complete the amended scheme the
council will have funds to undertake the
works
and we'll have the freehold title to the
property so that upon completion of the
approved scheme
those properties may be sold on the
market recovering any additional costs
incurred as a result of the works
if the developer completes the works
involved in the revised scheme the cash
deposit would go back to them
and the transfer of titles to the
property would not bite
members it's the recommendation of your
offices to amend the authority delegated
to the chief planning officer on the
14th of july
such that conditional planning
permission is granted subject to the
amendment to the section 106 agreement
at clause 7 of the minutes from that
meeting so that it involves the deposit
of 130 000 pounds
with the council
and the transfer of title to the council
in the event of default by the developer
thank you
first yes i wanted to ask the questions
of whether we can actually pursue this
today um because we're proposing to
alter something that was agreed at a
previous meeting
and normally we would have the
parish council involved the local ward
member involved
and lots of other people as well i
suppose
none of that is happening here we seem
to be overriding that that don't seem
somehow quite wrong can you tell me how
we arrive at this situation where we can
really decide that 250 000 which is what
the committee
uh said
um it can now be just altered like that
to 130 thousand and none of these other
people can have a comment on it surely
that's can't be right
um thank you counselor it's an uh it is
an urgent item uh they were obviously
they were given time the developers
given time in order to
um secure a bond as per the resolution
of the 14th of july
um
but the the time for them to achieve
that is between that decision and the
the deadline for the enforcement notice
the compliance with the enforcement
notice which is tomorrow
hence the reason we've put it before you
today for this this amendment
uh because in the absence of a
resolution
and then able to achieve what that
resolution requires we would then be
looking at them complying with the
enforcement notice so technically those
two buildings should be
ground level by tomorrow
but they're not going to be because the
developer hopes that they will be still
be able to pursue this with an amended
resolution from yourselves
but if obviously your decision is not to
agree that then they'll have no option
but to comply with the enforcement
notice i think my point mr chairman was
have we consulted with
the ward member and the parish council
because they were involved in all this
social reform
then i'll give you some other answers
um
chairman just to say i agree with and
endorse um mr bailey's comment um
the council's constitution does allow
for urgent items because obviously they
shouldn't be done at the drop of a hat
it's
not a small matter to
consider something without the normal
formalities of
uh notice etc and this mr bailey's
explained why there was a serious time
constraint here which is ties in with
the
great concern that the members have had
and local people have had about
compliance with the enforcement notice
and this
development being the unauthorized
development being in place a long time
indeed we have taken advice from council
from the leading council queen's council
who represents us very well in the
appeal recently and
i was at the same virtual meeting mr
bailey was at it
as he's explained it's not we're not
seeking to fundamentally change the
decision that was made last time but to
adjust it's it's not it's a significant
adjustment we'll acknowledge that but
it's
our advice as officers is that the
um and council has endorsed the the
element of risk is being mitigated as
best may practically be and of course
it's a matter lawyers don't tell you
councils what to do in this context
matter of judgment for the committee
today but our advice is this is a
appropriate some comments to be read
doing this arrangements doing this um
and just to remind people in my mind
that that we talked about the fact that
we didn't want to inflict any more harm
on the people who were neighbors to coco
hill and that the what we decided last
time the park demolition of the house
would be the the way to go
um for those particular people and it's
bearing in mind that and the situation
we're in where with full demolition
tomorrow
i felt that it could come back to the
committee on this particular island
yeah i i take councillor beer's points
but
we're really only talking about
safeguarding the position of the council
where the
developer to go into liquidation
so it's not actually really a planning
matter it's more of a make sure that
what we've he said he's going to
undertake is undertaken if he doesn't
undertake it then we are covered to then
pursue the work and arrive at the final
agreed position
that we
as a council agreed in the planning
committee so although the other people
weren't involved i think basically what
we're doing is making sure that the
wishes that they
we agreed to are carried out with no
detrimental effect to the council
so we're holding that deposit 130 and
that's presumably being agreed with the
applicant so we know he has the money to
deposit because obviously
the problem with a bond he's got to go
to a bank and the bank is guaranteeing
that bond will clearly that wasn't
happening so as long as we've got that
and also we're in a slightly better
position because we're going to get the
freehold value of potentially two 500
000 pound houses which will then cover
our position if we have to sell them
if we do have to implement it and having
looked at the accounts of the developer
um i i i don't think that is a position
that he would go past um i think he will
so he has sufficient funds to do it and
clearly he has demonstrated that by
putting the 130 000 which i assume he
will want back so it's merely a safety
position for the council and uh it seems
to make sense so i'm very happy to
propose that we accept the
recommendation of the enforcement
officer
then we'll have the comments from the
award member i'm sure you you want to
hear what council baron has said
so councillor can you
please ask your questions
if um this doesn't go obviously if
they do lapse and how long would it take
you to take over the houses and
obviously take the money away from them
obviously we don't want to put more harm
on the people around them
yes thank you so
if this amendment doesn't go through
then their obligation is to comply with
the enforcement notice they're currently
on site with scaffolding taking
the roofs off those buildings so that
they can adjust them if they need to
take it all the way down to the ground
then it will be
a matter of weeks
sorry i mean if
this goes through
right and then obviously they don't do
what they're meant to be doing
what's the next stage what would you
have to do
and how long would it take
uh that's a difficult question to answer
it would be subject towards section 106
legal agreement so it would be with the
lawyers their lawyers primarily to draft
the agreement and
provide to us for our approval
i would need to defer to my legal
colleague in order to go through the
specifics of that but
the time scale for that we would hope
would be quick there is a draft section
106 legal agreement in doing the rounds
at present it would need to be amended
to the satisfaction of both parties um
once that's agreed they would then need
to deposit the money with us and the
exchange of title would be written into
that agreement
then it's only a matter of them
completing or us issuing the permission
them completing that permission and if
they don't we use their money that
they've given us
if they do complete we give the money
back and there's no impact on the title
any more questions to the officer
councilman
hi um
i think i remember from the last uh
meeting there's nobody actually in the
other houses there's nobody occupying
those houses
there's nobody occupying plots five and
six the two that are due today what
about the other plots and lots one to
four are are occupied yeah yes so it's
essential it's
yeah and there's existing development um
the neighboring
white horse house enlisted building
and other residents in numbers six and
seven on cuckoo hill and eversley
uh and surrounding yeah yeah thank you
thank you chair
in that case can we hear from the ward
member you have a statement
thank you chair
i'm not able to attend the meeting on
this urgent item but wish to add my
support for adopting measures to limit
or remove liability from baba should the
developer go into liquidation
it would seem to me as a layperson that
taking an unencumbered title of the
plots 5 and 6 in the unfortunate
circumstance
would provide the council with the
opportunity to remedy the building in
line with recent planning consent
thank you
thank you
that's from cancer melanie barrett are
there any more comments to me
i have a proposal
or the enforcement officer
recommendation i should say
to
secure the 130 000 deposit and the
freehold entitlement should the
development not
go oh sorry should the developer go into
liquidation
do you have the secondary
council
we'll go to your vote if there's no
chairman i was just just going to say
that rather than if i did have a
question for the for the ward member but
i'll save it for her partner
if he can come out of here
you all happy with the question
are you happy with the proposal
oh yes yes yes chad yeah sure
me
[Applause]
one minute okay
checking the word
members of that vote is now in progress
thank you
you
beer would you like me to take your vote
verbally
it's just gone through so
chair that's um
eight votes for one against and
councillor parker has left the meeting
so he hasn't upgraded
thank you
that's it for today folks thank you very
much i'll formally close the meeting at
12 35.
you